Trayvon Martin's will not go gently into
that good night and the poor kids ghost
can and will haunt us
seems until justice is done his shooter
the neighborhood watch captain George
Zimmerman has been arrested and charged
with second-degree murder so the wheels
of the legal system however slowly and
imperfectly are grinding forward but we
can't shake the death of 17-year old
Trayvon that's partly because it was
senseless and avoidable and also in part
because his shooting is being ridden
like Seabiscuit by everyone trying to
benefit their respective political sides
and agendas figures like Jesse Jackson
and Al Sharpton want to use the Martin
shooting to say them when it comes to
race little to nothing has changed in
America over the past 20 30 or 50 years
gun control advocates want to say the
shooting proves that America is awash in
the blood of gun violence egged on by
Second Amendment fundamentalists but
neither of those things is true while
there's still a lot of work to be done
race relations are getting better in
this country that's clear from a
majority of black white Latino and other
respondents in poll after poll electing
Barack Obama doesn't give us a free pass
on the nation's ugly history but it's a
pretty good indicator that things aren't
the way they used to be and gun violence
in every way is down to where it was
just a few decades ago when most states
and localities started to allow more
people to own and carry guns that's true
even in Florida which liberalized it's
done laws years ago leading people to
worry it would become the gun shine
state in fact Florida's death rate from
guns its average for the country we're
all saddened by Trayvon Martin's death I
don't think George Zimmerman should have
pursued them and confronts them after
calling the cops who told them to stay
away but I also think that we can only
negatively
how the tragedy if we insist on making
it embody trends that are actually
moving in positive directions for recent
TV I'm Kennedy
you